this is Istanbul's newest mosque and
today opened by reject type erdogan
the president has reshaped turkey
giving himself vast power disrupting
Global diplomacy picking battles with
the West
he's now ging up his supporters for the
weekend's presidential election
[Applause]
three hours away in the city of Bursa
support amid the bustle
this stool holder tells me he loves the
president from the heart that he'd vote
for him a million times if he could
but in truth erdogan's grip on power is
under strain
his political opponents have United
behind a single candidate welcomed by
ever bigger crowds
it's this man Kamal
talking to us in his final broadcast
interview before the election telling me
his country's been damaged by erdogan
for you do you want to be the president
of Turkey or really do you want erdogan
to stop being the president
um
he tells me he will reconcile his
country support Sweden joining NATO and
repair turkey's fractured international
relations please
are you worried about any dirty tricks
on the day of the election
thanks
for
foreign
turkey's opposition parties will come up
to this stage to deliver one her final
speeches before Sunday's election and
that is the scene that will greet him
thousands of thousands of his supporters
increasingly confident that he will be
the next president
tells them to work for a brighter future
his logo is a heart symbol many here see
him as the opportunity for a new start
I am 44 years old 20 years maybe the
best years of my life have been spent
under oppression and intimidation and in
an atmosphere of crisis
alongside her teenagers who've never
known life without erdogan
is not someone who's going to live in
the palace
killistarolu is the face of Change
craved by many but others across this
country are happy or reconciled with
what they've got this will be a close
election in a desperately divided nation
Adam Parson Sky News bursa